hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on call compliance Solutions I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about CMC
control
si.l1-3.14.5 perform periodic scans of
organizational systems and real-time
scans of files from external sources as
files are downloaded opened or executed
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor is
feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all the cmmc dfars
and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff on
top of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news you found your home
here at on-call compliance Solutions
where we can help you transform into
your company's on-call compliance Hero
Let's jump into it so on this control we
are specifically directed on exactly how
our antivirus and endpoint management
programs should be set up specifically
it should be set up to one run routine
scans at specified intervals two set up
to scan on insertion download and
execution remember not all antivirus
products can do this and many more are
not configured to do this out of the box
so you really need to dive into the
specifics of how this is configured and
make sure it's working in alignment with
this control let's take a minute and
look at the exact assessment points to
get more clarity three assessment points
on this one determine if the frequency
for malicious code scans is defined
now
if we were to give a sample answer we
would say hey it's implemented malicious
code scan frequency is defined within
XYZ you know maybe it's a policy or
maybe it's a technical system like the
endpoint management system itself lots
of different answers you can have there
but ultimately we want to say that there
is a scan frequency and it's defined
here
second assessment Point determine if
malicious code scans are performed with
the defined frequency again they really
want to know what your frequency is they
really want you to find that so we'd say
hey evidence of malicious code scans can
be found in whatever the console is or
the endpoint management uh you know sort
of pane of glasses if you will and again
you want to provide evidence so you
might want to say hey antibioter scans
run routinely every seven days or on
demand as things are downloaded executed
or inserted in the system
final assessment Point determine if
real-time malicious code scans of files
from external sources as files are
downloaded open or executed this is
implemented via endpoint management
solution monitored and audited by seam
solution yes lots of different things
coming into play here but again your
seam solution is a great way that you
can monitor and audit those things so uh
if you're struggling to figure all this
stuff out or you're just trying to put
the other pieces your system and you
need an easier way to deal with it the
great news is that an on-call we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this defars nist itar and
CMC compliance stuff dropped in their
laps like a single on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance here
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance Dot Com or
check out the bio below for links to get
help right now if you love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliances roll it out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
foreign